it's hard to believe there's been 40
years since I passed that real-estate
test I did take it 25 minutes I could
get a 94 but nowadays real estate tests
are a lot harder I was 18 years old and
I sold a house two weeks later now let
me just help you with this if you buy a
house from an eighteen year old three
weeks after he got his real estate
license you're not smarter
I appreciate my old high school buddy
left me selling my house we were both
just out of high school oh my gosh
me and my disco clothes oh and I had
hair oh can you imagine I was driving a
two-door car showing houses oh my
goodness
real-estate business I love the real
estate business I grew up in the
business obviously the reason I got my
license at that age mom and dad own the
company and I wanted to be a real estate
mogul I went and got my real estate and
finance degree as a matter of fact my
degree in finance as a specialization in
real estate and sold real estate all the
way through college even in those high
interest rate days and even though I was
as green as a Gordon didn't know what I
was doing I I sure thought I would knew
what I was doing and I convinced a few
people I didn't know what I was doing
but and I got some houses sold so I did
the job but man oh man oh man what a
business I love the business I love real
estate I love helping you guys buy
houses and you know we've got 2000 or so
endorsed local providers across America
now that we endorse and when you get
ready to buy a house these days it's a
complicated process it was complicated
way back then but it's really
complicated now and there's all this bad
information because you know everything
on the internet is not true right I mean
you know because as illo says it's worth
something doesn't mean it's worth that
you know the tax assessor well the tax
value who cares tax value has absolutely
nothing to do with market value it's
supposed to but it doesn't you can't use
that as your gauge so you have to learn
this is the most expensive thing most
people ever buy
and you know it's an emotional process
you get excited I was out this morning
riding around I was looking at some
properties and some buildings on some
properties getting learning some things
and I just got real estate fever this
morning it happened to me again it's
happened to me like a bazillion times in
my life you ever get the fever
you get house fever when you get house
fever you get stupid you're willing to
pay too much you're excited you've got
to focus and you're willing to buy a
house when you're not supposed to buy a
house you're not ready to buy a house
you're gonna sell a house the wrong way
oh man you can get a real mess so let me
give you a couple things you need to do
if you're thinking about buying a house
and I want you to own real estate owning
a home and paying it off is one of the
data points of an everyday millionaire
so we want you to do that but we don't
want the house telling you so here's
your rule of thumb okay number one you
don't buy a house unless you're out of
debt and you have your emergency fund
now everybody's going to tell you you
need to run buy a house but everybody's
broke and you don't listen to them it's
not a popular thing to be move a little
slower with more maturity and more
wisdom but it gives a crap this is not a
popularity contest this is you your
family trying to build wealth and build
stability and sustainability don't buy a
house until your debt free and you have
your emergency fund and then you save up
your down payment and that's what we do
ding-ding just like that and then when
you do buy a house I love the hundred
percent down plan I love it when I talk
to a young couple these men these killer
Millennials that I get to talk to
they're incredible and they say you know
we got married we were 23 years old and
we lived in a garage apartment and we
were making a hundred and ten thousand
dollars a year and we say fifty thousand
dollars a year for four years and we
were twenty eight we paid cash for a two
hundred thousand dollar house I love the
hundred percent down plan and people are
doing it by the way I recommend that but
if you're not gonna do that here's the
most you should borrow and it's the only
thing I don't yell at you for borrowing
but I I would prefer you didn't borrow
or that you borrow or less less less
less and get
paid off as soon as possible but the
most you should borrow is a home on a
15-year fixed-rate where the payment is
no more than 1/4 of your take-home pay
so don't buy home until you're debt-free
have your emergency fund plus a down
payment on a 15-year fixed-rate where
the payments no more than 1/4 of your
take-home pay and when you pick a
realistic do not do real estate DIY this
is not DIY okay this is a two hundred
three hundred one hundred and fifty
thousand dollar transaction you don't
work on your car and that's a one
thousand dollar transaction you don't
open up the back of your computer and
try to fix that and that's a five
hundred dollar transaction and yet you
somehow think you're just gonna waddle
up and not get in a bad deal buying a
house or selling a house you make a
mistake selling a two hundred thousand
dollar house if you if you make a ten
percent mistake that's $20,000 think
about that I mean if you make a one
percent mistake it's $2,000 count out
ten $2,100 uncle Benjamin Franklin's
right in front of you on the table right
now in your mind that's one percent and
if you're a novice if you've bought and
sold 10 houses you're a novice you are
likely to make a one percent mistake at
a minimum without a pro in your corner
so you put pro in your corner it's that
simple
you don't do this without a pro now
everybody's got a real estate license is
not a pro your Aunt Sally who got her
license three weeks ago is not a pro
she's a sweet Aunt Sally but she's a
novice and you don't put her in charge
of your largest asset because she's your
Aunt Sally lance and you get her
feelings hurt well so what she's like
let it screw it up more than you are if
you did it by yourself because she's an
enthusiastic ignoramus no no no no no no
well I know this guy Church oh good
Lord you don't pick anything else out
that way you don't we you know when you
need to get a mechanic you don't go on
my Uncle Henry got a toolbox last week
and so I'm gonna let him work on the car
no you look at their Yelp ratings you
talk to them you find out if they're a
pro how long you've been working on cars
and 26 years okay I got an ASE
certification okay we'll let you get
your butt under the hood but other than
that no I bought a you know I was in a
Holiday Inn Express last night and I
bought two boxes on the sale all over
Sears when they're going broke no you're
not a mechanic
no you're not a real estate agent yeah
you got a license but just because the
state certified you doesn't mean
anything
listen you want someone that's a pro you
want someone if you're buying a house or
selling a house that's doing 50 to 300
transactions a year if they've not done
50 transactions in their entire freakin
life no no no no no no no no well I'm
gonna sell it myself that's stupid
you're not gonna make any money on that
again if you make a 2% error all of a
sudden you didn't save anything well I'm
saving a 6% Commission no you're not
because likely the person buying it is
gonna bring their agent up you're gonna
pay that agent 3% now you're only saving
3% but you've been on the market twice
as long and you undersold the property
and you didn't know what the what you
were signing up for with the home
inspection and what you tied yourself
into to do repairs that you didn't
intend to do oh when you miscalculated
the closing costs you ate up any
possible savings because you don't know
what to flip you're doing stop that stop
it
so you get a pro that's why we vet these
pros for you the entree the entree well
they are on trade leadership they go
through on trade leadership but the
endorse local providers for real estate
they're the best of the best they're
high octane high protein in your area
and if you get ready to buy a house or
sell a house you need a pro somebody
really knows their stuff and we've
vetted them for you and if you're
thinking about buying a home and you
think you got house fever and you but
you meet the guidelines we're talking
about I can help you with this our new
home buyers guide starts out by teaching
you real estate lingo
what to expect at the closing what
happens after the signing on the dotted
line it's got the questions you need to
ask an agent when you're interviewing
them and it's completely free to
download go to Dave Ramsey comm slash
home buyers guide or go to the site and
look for the yellow banner at the top
the home buyers guide it's a free
download for you Dave Ramsey comm / home
buyers guide or the yellow banner at the
top it's free this is the Dave Ramsey
show